what i want to do in this video is think
about how does the value of an
expression change as a variable that
makes up that expression changes so
let's start with a pretty simple
expression let's say we have the
expression 100
minus x we want to know how does this
expression change as x increases
as x increases and like always try to
work it out for yourself pause the video
before i try to have a go at it
well there's a couple of ways you could
think about it you say okay i have a
hundred and i'm subtracting x
so as x increases as x increases over
here i'm going to be subtracting larger
and larger values so if i'm subtracting
larger and larger values i'm going to
get smaller and smaller values so this
whole thing
this whole thing is going to decrease
and if you want to make it a little bit
more
concrete you can actually try out some
values there so you can make a little
table here x and then what is a hundred
minus x going to be and i'm just going
to pick some values of x i'm gonna make
them increase say x is zero
x is fifty
x is one hundred well when x is zero a
hundred minus x is a hundred minus zero
so it's a hundred
when x is fifty it's going to be a
hundred minus fifty so it's going to be
fifty
when x is a hundred it's a hundred minus
a hundred so it's zero
so it's pretty clear here that as x is
increasing
as x is increasing i'll just write
anchor for short for increasing we see
we see that 100 minus x is decreasing
we see that that is decreasing let's do
this with a couple of more expressions
that have different forms
so let's say that i have the expression
let's say that i have the expression
five
over x
plus five
and
x is decreasing
but we also know that it is positive and
it's and even while it's decreasing it's
staying above zero so we're saying
x is staying
greater than zero
so in this case so you know this could
be a situation where x is decreasing
from 10 to nine or a million
to
a hundred thousand but it's staying
positive while it's decreasing
let's think about that
we are going to be dividing by smaller
and smaller positive values
so as you decrease as you as you have
smaller and smaller positive values in
the denominator you're dividing by
smaller and smaller positive values so
if you're dividing by smaller positive
values you're going to this thing is
going to get larger this entire
expression is going to get larger as you
divide by smaller and smaller positive
values so if that expression gets larger
then you're just adding 5 to it the
whole thing is going to increase
the whole thing is going to increase
as
the whole thing is going to increase as
x decreases while staying positive and
once again we can make a little table to
take a look at that
so
if this is x
this is five over x
plus five and let's see i'll just try
out some let's see if x i'll go from x
go 100 to x is to x is five
to x is one so this is clearly x is
decreasing
x is decreasing when x is a hundred
you're going to have five divided by a
hundred which would be five hundredths
plus five so it'd be five point zero
five
when x is five you're going to have 5
divided by 5 which is 1
plus 5 which is 6.
and when x is 1 you're going to have 5
divided by 1 which is 5 plus 5 is just
10. so notice when x is staying positive
but decreasing
the whole expression 5 over x plus 5
this thing right over here is increasing
increasing let's do one more of these
so let's say that we have the expression
and we'll change up the variable here 3y
over
2y and i'm curious what happens to this
about the value of this expression as y
as y increases
well
as as as you have larger y's here on the
numerator you're also going to have
larger y's here in the denominator and
one way you could think about this this
is the same thing as three halves
times y over y and no matter what y you
have here as long as it's not equal to
zero actually let's just assume that it
doesn't cross zero because at that point
at that point this thing would become
undefined let's just say that y
increases and y is greater than zero
just for simplicity so y is y is a
positive value here and actually for any
positive for any non-zero value you take
y you divide by y you're just gonna get
one so it doesn't matter what y is y
could be a million over a million this
thing's just going to be 1 y could be 5
over 5 it's still just going to be 1.
the value of the expression is not going
to change it's just going to be 3 halves
so the expression is just going to be
the same you're not you're not going to
have any change as y increases as y is
positive and it increases